Я мщуся? В мене робота зараз триває.
Людині треба до психіатра сходити.
Чи замислювалися ви про відставку?
Замислювався, і не раз. Ще до подій з акваріумом.
- Доброго дня, пане Холодницький.
- Доброго дня.
Ви, ймовірно, читали на сайті DW інтерв’ю пана Ситника,
голови НАБУ,
яке DW взяла в нього в Німеччині.
Відповідно ви чули про те, що, на його думку,
єдиним висновком комісії з приводу подальшої вашої долі
може бути лише одне – ваше звільнення.
Все інше, на думку пана Ситника, - маніпуляція законом про прокуратуру.
Чи згодні ви з цим?
Комісія для того і створена, щоб надавати свої висновки,
а коли високопосадовці такого рангу, як пан Ситник,
розказують і висловлюють свої думки
і таким чином тиснуть на комісію, я вважаю, що це неправильно.
І  це аж ніяк не свідчить про демократичність власне установи, яку він очолює,
і про ті демократичні прояви і напрями, про які він голослівно заявляє.
І я, наприклад, до висновків комісії не беруся коментувати будь-які з висновків,
з різних думок і тлумачень, тому що
будь-яке слово може буде тлумачене як тиск.
Ви самі чули ці записи розмов з вашого кабінету?
Я чув те що було продемонстровано в YouTube,
те, що було оприлюднено,
не знаю, як там була дотримана законність щодо розголошення,
але я чув лише нарізки, я не чув повністю записи.
Я чув нарізки, які можна дуже легко скомпілювати і
і показати так, як вигідно комусь.
Так само, як, знаєте, можна пару слів записати тут у кабінеті
і потім показувати, що щось тут відбувається,
хоча жодного значення для справ вони не мають.
Тобто це ваш голос?
Я впізнаю голос, схожий на мій - скажу так.
Доки не буде висновків слідства, я не буду нічого коментувати.
Якщо ми уявимо іншу ситуацію, протилежну:
Ви, САП, оприлюднєте записи розмов з кабінету пана Ситника
приблизно з таким змістом.
І що, ви не будете вимагати його звільнення?
По-перше, у мене навіть у думках такого не було.
По-друге, я не стільки зациклений на піарі, щоб
просто оприлюднити для оприлюднення,
як дехто оприлюднює протоколи негласних слідчих розшукових дій
жінки одного з наших підозрюваних, просто для сміху.
І чомусь тут ніхто не бачить жодних порушень.
Так має бути, напевно? Це ж боротьба з корупцією по-українськи.
Комусь можна все, а іншим - закон.
І вимагати звільнення, вимагати ще чогось,
кричати на всіх телеканалах і розказувати, що  всі всім заважають, -
це простіше  всього. У мене є, наприклад, питання,
чому протягом двох років моніторилися аналітиками НАБУ
реєстри майнові керівництва САП і прокурорів.
На підставі чого? Адже ні провадження, ні оперативно-розшукових справ заведено не було.
Я думаю, слідство це все встановить. У мене є питання, чому
детективи і їхні керівники, попри чітку вимогу КПК,
обговорюють з втікачами-олігархами питання укладення угод,
коли це виключно прерогатива прокурора.
Тобто ви стверджуєте, що ви нічого не порушили? Я правильно розумію?
Я стверджую те, що комісія повинна надати висновок.
Але як процесуальний керівник я мав право спілкуватися
зі стороною захисту,
як процесуальний керівник у конкретних провадженнях
я зобов’язаний вживати заходів на скарги, в тому числі
сторони захисту на дії як підлеглих прокурорів, так і детективів.
Якщо говорити про якісь морально-етичні дії,
то це все покажуть висновки комісії.
Можливо, в певних випадках мною було допущено міцне слівце.
Бо коли до мене приходить прокурор і пояснює, що ми зараз  перевернемо офіс бізнесмена,
який сплачує мільйонні податки, просто так, не знаю чого,
бо "я думав, що все погоджено", ось така відповідь мені була, я як керівник не можу з цим змиритися.
Якщо ми декларуємо, що ми бізнесу дозволяємо розвиватися
і ми забезпечуємо так званий закон "маски-шоу стоп",
треба це робити не словом, а ділом.
Можете пояснити причину, чому ви звертаєтеся до кваліфікаційно-дисциплінарної комісії
і просите не брати до уваги ці записи розмов з вашого кабінету?
Це не до комісії, це до суду, тому що
кожен має право на захист в суді.
Так само робили всі, так само робив директор НАБУ Ситник, коли
проти нього НАЗК склав адмінпротокол.
Він також пішов до суду.
Моя позиція проста і ця позиція юридично правильна, я вважаю.
Кримінально-процесуальний кодекс визначає чітку рамку застосування негласних слідчо-розшукових дій.
Це є застосування в рамках кримінальних проваджень.
Дані, які були отримані в рамках НСРД в рамках кримінального провадження,
повинні використовуватись лише в рамках кримінального провадження. Це перше.
По-друге, КПК чітко містить норму, яка визначає, що
забороняється знімати копії з протоколів негласних слідчо-розшукових дій.
Ці протоколи були надані на кваліфікаційно-дисциплінарну комісію прокурорів
в рамках дисциплінарного провадження. Я свою позицію обґрунтовую і
я вважаю її юридично правильною.
Прислухається чи не прислухається суд… враховуючи, що перенесли засідання на вересень,
то вже не буде мати значення.
Справа Борислава Розенблата.
Ваші прокурори разом з детективами НАБУ цілий рік вели цю справу.
І лише зараз, після скандалу навколо вас,
відбувається те ж саме: САП каже, що
детективи сфальсифікували докази.
Коли ми отримуємо в процесі проведення слідства документи -
протоколи, прокурори зараз фактично не зобов’язані слухати, що на дисках.
Ми віримо тим протоколам, які нам приносять слідчі.
От ми віримо, розумієте?
А наша віра вже потім, на стадії, коли справа має йти до суду,
обривається, бо ми відкриваємо стороні захисту всі матеріали
по закону, а вони і бачать, і слухають, і порівнюють.
А ми перед тим, ми вірили, що ці слова відповідають тим звукам, які записані.
А тепер змушені переслухувати все самі.
Тому що виявляються факти, де слова надруковані не відповідають звукам, які записані.
А ми вірили до того часу, бо нам, прокурорам САП,
в голову не могло прийти, що протоколи НСРД можуть не відповідати записам.
Тим більше враховуючи, що на 250 детективів є всього-навсього 35 прокурорів.
Це є елемент довіри, він відіграє ключове значення.
Чому почалось провадження (проти детектива - Ред.)?
Тому що надійшло заява захисника Полякова про те, що
"слухайте, ми ознайомились з матеріалами справи, а там
в протоколі написано одне, а на записі ми того не чуємо".
А ми ж вірили!
Чому немає єдності між САП і НАБУ?
Це ж відбулося нещодавно, фактично.
Півроку тому все було по-іншому. В чому справа? Реально можете сказати?
Єдність слідства завжди є.
Там, де є міцна доказова база, там завжди є підозри і будуть справи направлені до суду.
Одне від одного не залежить, просто зараз
сталось так, що дійсно є питання довіри, бо
ті факти, на жаль, є не поодинокі.
Коли, наприклад, подаємо одне клопотання з додатками до суду,
а в суд приходить детектив і приносить щось інше, без тих документів, які вказані в змісті.
Питаємо: чому? Відповідь: ми вирішили, що цього показувати не треба.
Ви вирішили без прокурора, що це показувати не треба, але прокурору доводити вину в суді.
Коли Україна створювала НАБУ і САП,
це все дуже сильно підтримували західні політики, західні експерти.
Але коли НАБУ заявила, що САП нібито намагається
прикрутити гайки, як то кажуть, теж пролунало багато жорстких реакцій
з боку Заходу і зараз, коли відбувається скандал навколо вас,
цих записів у кабінеті, таких реакцій немає.
Вас це не ображає?
Ні, не ображає, тому що ми робимо свою роботу для країни, а не для західних партнерів
чи для когось іншого. Ми повинні показувати якісно нові реформи,
ми повинні розслідувати справи згідно норми закону.
Ми повинні притягувати корупціонерів не просто через те, що в них прізвища відомі
і апріорі вони вже злочинці тому, що так телебачення каже.
Я повинен довести - от беремо справу Насірова, - я повинен довести як прокурор, що
Насіров поганий не тому, що він голова фіскальної служби,
не тому, що він митник (митарів не любили ще з біблійних часів),
а я повинен довести, що ця особа вчинила цей злочин в конкретний час, в конкретному місці,
за конкретних обставин. І незважаючи на те, хто там буде на цій посаді -
чи буде Іванов, Петров, чи Сідоров,
А мені кажуть: ні, давайте всіх суддів оголосимо злочинцями,
а там потім щось під них підкопаємо.
В когось машина, в когось квартира, хтось з кимось в інтимних відносинах
і це будемо потім використовувати. Я так не хочу працювати,
бо це не є метод новостворених органів, це методи НКВД,
це методи радянських спецслужб, так не можна працювати.
Йде перекручення всього.
Ми просто країну скинемо в якусь анархію,
тому що будуть полювати на людей, які займають посади.
Пан Ситник впевнений, що таким чином ви просто мститеся детективам.
Яким чином? Я мщуся? У мене робота зараз триває.
Детективи працюють. Приносять документи, погоджуються обшуки,
якщо на це є необхідність.
У мене на столі лежить проект підозри,
так і не реалізований,
за який два роки тому мене змішували з лайном, що я там гальмую все, що тільки можна.
Вибачте, там 196 граматичних помилок на 11 аркушах.
Коли прокурор каже: "Я ж з таким не піду в суд",
детектив відповідає прокуророві: "Так напишіть, як вам зручніше, хай буде так".
Ну так не можна.
Коли по справі є висновки Верховного Суду
і ми знаємо, що ми програємо кримінальний суд,
як ми можемо йти в суд тільки тому, що там далеко звучить ім'я якогось олігарха,
десь далеко, і...
Мститися? Ну, в людини просто параноя,
Йому всі мстяться, за ним всі стежать, його всі прослуховують.
Людині треба до психіатра сходити.
Це ви розумієте, так, що ви зараз сказали?
Як це оцінювати, я не знаю, але в будь-якому разі:
ви хочете далі працювати в таких умовах?
- В яких умовах?
- Ну, це доволі складно.
Я не прийшов сюди, щоб просто піти.
Тому що так комусь  захотілось.
Процес триває. Все, що нас не вбиває, робить нас сильнішими - є така гарна українська приказка.
Я налаштований на бій. Ми будемо показувати результат.
Як будете працювати з паном Ситником?
Пан Ситник не є детективом.
Пан Ситник не є керівником органу досудового розслідування згідно вимог КПК.
В мене є детективи, в мене є прокурори.
Детективи підписують одні процесуальні документи. Прокурори їм погоджують чи не погоджують.
І процес цей йде. Незалежно від того, що буде говорити чи пан Ситник, чи інші -
його спонсори, олігархи і інші особи, які йому співчувають,
процес цей буде йти.
Мене цікавить справу Роттердам + завершити,
мене цікавить у справі "Приватбанку" поставити крапку,
хто ж там був винуватий у цій справі.
Мене цікавить справа Запорізького титано-магнієвого комбінату, де ми
попри те, що судове засідання слухається раз на три місяці,
але ми сьогодні в рамках господарського судочинства
зробили перший крок щодо повернення комбінату державі.
У мене просто, напевно, інші пріоритети, ніж у пана Ситника.
Мені важливіше розслідувати і викрити багатомільярдну корупційну схему,
ніж викрити 5-10 суддів районних судів
на 100, 300 доларах хабарів за винесення рішення.
Тобто у вас різниця є, чи як?
У мене бачення: якщо це є
боротьба з топ-корупцією, то вона повинна бути топ.
Чи вважаєте ви, що ця боротьба є успішною сьогодні?
Ця боротьба зараз
проходить низку випробувань.
Я скажу так.
Але вона триває.
Ви ж розумієте, що суспільство чекає на покарання реальні?
Суспільство чекає на покарання і ми сподіваємось, що Антикорупційний суд ці покарання нам покаже.
Або покаже виправдальні вироки, якщо доказів виявиться недостатньо на думку суду.
Але тоді вже, якщо будуть виправдальні вироки,
кричати, що в усьому винен продажний і старий суд,
вже буде ні на кого.
Чи замислювались ви про відставку?
Замислювався, і не раз.
І ще до подій з акваріумом ("жучкі" для прослуховування в кабінеті Холодницького були на акваріумі - Ред.).
Вперше почав замислюватись ще в вересні 2017 року.
Скажу відверто: є моральна втома,
є бажання щось змінити, в тому числі у своєму житті,
але не піти обпльованим, тому що так комусь захотілось.
Я можу бути яким хочеш прокурором: можу бути лайливим,
можу бути наглим,
але я був, є і залишаюсь антикорупційним.
Я як прийшов на цю посаду з квартири в Вишневому,
так і вернуся в цю квартиру у Вишневому з цієї посади.
Не в Конча-Заспу, не в Козин, не в інші елітні села.
І все майно, що в мене було, воно все було задекларовано і показано до вступу на цю посаду.
Нового якогось значного майна я не набув.
Все моє майно - це, фактично, зарплата.
Хіба що поміняв авто в 2016 році.
Продав старий, доплатив, купив новіший, але не новий,
а 2013-го року випуску.
Ви не збираєтесь розпочати теж прослуховування скрізь геть усього?
У мене немає таких повноважень і, знаєте,
я не буду мститися точно. Хай там хто що не каже.
Але те, що тепер прокурори стали уважніше читати документи - всі, які надходять,
ну, хай подякують собі.